[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
the handmaid's tale season four
episode four milk this is directed by
christina cho
written by jc heldrick i'm going to give
a special shout out to the
cinematographer this episode
berenice avino and as always the
composer adam taylor
and the reason i'm mentioning them here
is because i think they really were such
an integral
part to this episode which i'll delve
more into this episode really centers on
rita
and janine so i'm gonna actually break
down my review we'll start with rita's
side of the episode and then we'll
finish off with janine june's storyline
so what you really see in read a story
but you also see
in janine and june's story here and when
i'm talking about why the cinematography
is so
amazing to me in this episode important
is because you have to look at how
they're doing the lighting here so
we know what the lighting of gilead
looks like right where it's always like
this
interior shot but there's like light
peering through
really bright through different types of
sources like a window
and they set the scene with that where
we first see rita in this episode from
behind and she's pouring out the flower
it looks just like it did when she was
in gilead with that light seeping in
and this will go on throughout the
episode in all of rita's scenes
and in a couple of janine and june
scenes and to me it's always just
showing you that
gilead is always with these people it's
following these people and especially in
rita's story
it's still a part of her and dealing
with the stockholm syndrome she has from
being in gilead so long
so i love that this episode the lighting
in particular
speaks volumes and reminding you
subconsciously about
where these people have been so what's
really interesting is moira here
showing up to rita and giving her this
sad news that there's no record
of her nephew or her sister in the
refugee camps
and remember too rita has a son that we
know was in the war
they haven't told us yet which side he
was fighting on but there's a lot of
mystery behind rita and her personal
life
the big news for rita here is that
serena joy wants to see her
and what i like they did was it shows
the difference of rita's character
compared to other handmaids we knew like
moira because moyra is like doing people
would kill to
just have an opportunity to say their
peace to this woman and
that's not how rita rolls rita does it a
different way
she's not someone who's just gonna go to
your face and yell at you and air her
grievances
she's gonna kind of get her revenge in a
very classy style
and again the little things i love how
it transitions to when we see serena now
that again that gilead light is just
shining bright on her that is all serena
stands for right and what's really
interesting is when serena informs rita
now of this
baby that the important real information
for rita to hear is that fred doesn't
know about it
and this is the beginning of rita's
master plan here that
she was gonna get a revenge on serena
and fred by actually telling fred about
the baby
and it hits her hard where she says to
serena like crying it's a boy because
she has a son herself
and serena wants her to help her take
care of this little boy
and this is the complication rita has
with
serena and it felt so villainous of
serena saying the line
i've missed you my lovely rita because
it comes from such a self-centered oh
now i need rita
and she's useful again to me and never
apologizing serena she's not
saying sorry for the way we treat you
readers sorry for slapping you there's
none of that and i think what this show
does well
is you start to get on serena liking her
a bit and then you hate her again right
but we all bash fred but there's a
reason because serena is this female
that
you're like come on wake up you know
smell the coffee what you're doing
what's happening but
the end of the day it's almost like she
is really the most villainous
character in the show because she's had
so many opportunities to change she's
given so many second chances
and i think they're reminding you that
and how hard it is for even people like
rita to deal with serena because
it's it's just difficult it's this bond
they still
sort of had but she doesn't like serena
but there's something there and
again goes to the stockholm syndrome and
i'm not gonna explain it
as good as amanda brugel herself and
there's my
advertisement during this review because
i interviewed amanda brugel who plays
rita
all about this episode and she
breaks down rita's mindset really well
better than i ever could so
check out that link to that interview
down below and what really rubs rita the
wrong way is when mark shows up and
informs her that
serena's defense attorney wants her to
do an interview and basically
just get her someone to say that serena
again was
only doing bad things because of her
duress under fred which we know is not
true
and rita knows that and again seems like
people always want to give her a pass
but she's just as bad i love the line
rita says
i was considered property of the
waterford family
registered in everything like my old
nissan altima
who had in their bedding pool that rita
drove a nissan altima
in the past congrats and when rita now
goes to fred
he says it's nice to see a friendly face
and you see more of rita's
no mask on like she kind of hates serena
towards fred where she's just being
herself here and is like we're not
friends
you deal with your family it's not my
job anymore and thank god for that every
day
hands him the baby pic mic drop moment
for rita
crowd pleasing moment and he's like oh
it's never cruel to you but she's like
i'll pray for your son
she definitely means that she obviously
feels bad for this child that that son's
parents are going to be
the waterfords but this is huge because
it's a blow she knows
to serena and fred here and this is
really exciting for the storyline of the
show for fred to already find out about
this and
how he's going to react to serena it's
the best way rita could have
screwed over serena now the thing i
really want to compliment
is that the last shot we see of rita
here was one of the top
five shots of this show so far to close
out a storyline in an
episode that rita here properly
eats still like that gilead style she's
holding on to and praise over her food
but this time
it's not like that bread that she keeps
eating and the gilead food she makes for
everybody
it's actually take out sushi with a diet
coke here
and that gilead light is still gleaming
on her right but it's showing you the
choice of food she had here she's
transitioning a little bit out of this
old life now and
trying to get back to normalcy having
this take out sushi i thought
the whole shot everything about it the
subtext the visual language
just speaks volumes and it was brilliant
and it really works well again
which we'll get more into but this
ending
montage seeing the episode with the
beautiful music by adam taylor now again
check out my interview down below with
rita herself amanda brugel
again she does a way better job
explaining all this than i would ever do
it's a really fun time and she's super
cool so make sure you check that out
now let's go into janine and
june's storyline i love it i love when a
show anytime picks up right where we
left off
just keeping that momentum and it
totally does here how great is janine's
reactions to june all the time like
again janine's this innocent character
most
lovable character and she's like a
little kid to june's strict mom
right she's like let's go back and see
if they're okay
and jun's like they're dead i just love
madeleine brewer's reaction she's like
no like a little kid it really is
the best but june's plan is for him to
go west
follow the tracks and head towards
chicago
and find mayday but when i'm talking
about this june janine
motherly relationship she has where i'm
not gonna let anything happen to you she
says janine
it's gonna show the complications and
actually highlight
some of june's flaws as a leader in this
episode
and it works really well again we'll see
as the episode goes
and there's this intense scene i i never
thought i'd say that it would be an
intense scene where two people are
swimming
in a tank of milk but it was exciting
especially when that guard was up top
and they had to dunk in the milk
to get away i thought it was actually a
cool unique original setup here
but you see janine wants to go to sleep
but she could have a concussion
hypothermia so june's like you cannot go
to sleep
again as strict as june could be this is
so important
june is to everybody as bad as a rep she
might get with the fans
i'm always gonna be someone who supports
june here she's the leader she's the one
who's gonna make the tough decisions
but again i like how they highlight some
of the flaws which we'll get into
because this is where things get really
tense and they have a really big
argument here what i love about this
argument
it almost speaks to kind of the
arguments we had last week after episode
three of how responsible june is for
alma brienne the other handmaid's deaths
and janine is kind of the voice of some
of the audience here
but what it sets up thematically with
janine and jun's relationship
is janine saying i'm upset i'm not in
the no i'm always taking orders
basically from june
she says i'm not a mushroom you can't
just keep me in the dark and feed me
lies
and just be okay with it now this is
important because what you have to
remember
from this scene on is that later on the
episode in one of the flashbacks with
janine
that crazy counselor actually says to
her that
she doesn't like being underestimated
and it's so true about janine it's an
important line
and it's kind of her soft spot and
that's what this episode is going to
round out to
about june's flaw too that she
underestimates janine
and janine's never taken seriously and
it's not healthy to treat anybody like
that
and that june's got to trust more and be
aware of other people's feelings there
too
and she's got to let them more in on the
plans like she's saying and include
but you see this line janine says to
june they were the nicest alma
and brianna maybe that's why god wanted
them and not
us dot dot at least not you again
amazing delivery by madeline brewer here
that line just made me laugh really hard
but she's rubbing it into june here
she's like when we were at the
farm hiding alma's the one who said we
should wait for june they love you
and june just goes i know that i thought
that was just so
powerful this was such a great
confrontation confrontation in any
television is always really good and
it's good to see that happening a lot
this season in handmaid's tale and then
it gets really gritty here where janine
is like did you
tell them the eyes where we were but
june explains
hers side of it that she's like hey they
had hannah here you know
they were going to hurt her you would
have done the same thing but janine's
just like i wouldn't have told them
where we were you know that's why they
are dead
wow so this is hard to watch it's sad
it's kind of heartbreaking to see this
kind of argument between the two of them
now again shameless plug for me here but
i got to interview madeleine brewer
herself who plays janine obviously
and she's gonna give a great answer in
my interview about that line
and what she really thinks really
believes at the end of the day
i thought it was one of the best answers
i've heard an interview please check
that interview out she breaks down all
the stuff that you need in this episode
i think you'll really like that you'll
see a link down below but june has this
wicked line
to janine i should have left you a long
time ago but i think june had the right
to say that there after what janine just
said to her
it was a very serena joy-esque line by
june
but it was good you know we're airing
dirty laundry here between handmaids
they need to get this out that's how
we're gonna have growth in a
relationship right in a better
relationship
and healing so we cut to the much begged
for by the fans janine flashback
finally what's amazing about this
character of janine is there's
two characters of jeanine here there's
pre eye gouge jeanine and post i got
janine and she's someone you could
really see that direct extreme trauma
just completely changed someone from the
beginning
i actually forgot what the original
pre-eye gouging was like we only really
saw that
at the beginning of season one so it's
nice to see this again and it's a nice
touch cutting to the flashback from
janine and her handmaid's outfit that's
obviously the handmade
red and it's the handmade red of the
denny's work outfit now
but man did janine pick the wrong clinic
to go to
this is so interesting i think the most
interesting stuff in the show is when we
see
life when it was kind of transitioning
to gilead and early people in this
fertility crisis that we're going that
way and this is clearly this counselor
here
who's a complete wacko she's prying at
janine making her feel guilty asking her
questions are none of her business like
if she has a boyfriend
why she wants to do this that she should
keep the baby
and just gives her all these horrible
things that could happen if she has an
abortion
also wants to know if she's religious
and look she's like we don't even do
abortions here and that shocks janine
and it's
interesting because you're seeing again
how that world was changing in the
fertility crisis and how
already these gilead belief systems were
forming and really just
saying awful stuff like all women regret
doing this janine
no one's fine after killing their baby
this is some heavy stuff heavy duty
topic here just that obviously released
a lot of people going through situations
like this
this is probably a very sensitive
episode to people hearing
lines like this so again make sure
you're ready for this kind of stuff
it's heavy duty but like i mentioned
before she says this line i know you're
used to being underestimated again which
is really setting up the theme for
janine this episode and why she does
what she does at the end of the episode
which we'll get to
but again when i'm talking about the
brilliant cinematography and how he sets
up his lighting is that
it cuts in to present day in the milk
tank but we see the hole in the milk
tank the lights coming through and it
opens
clearly with the shot focusing on that
light coming through that hole
on to june again gilead's always
following them but what's interesting is
you hear gunshots here
they're on a gilead train so june makes
a connection like look if it's someone
shooting the guillotine these gotta be
allies maybe this is mayday
i love when we see these scavengers
though when they have the guns when
janine actually finally comes out she's
just like hi
just so i mean come on how great is
janine and i'm not just saying that
because i interviewed her like i've said
this
since day one and it's just always a
treat and it's good to see her getting
some serious screen time here but when
you watch this episode again
you just go oh no because when that guy
with the long hair comes out
he's like why should we trust you and
june says we'll do anything you say we
need you so now when you look back at
this you're like oh god
and that's really the reason why this
guy even took them on and janine
actually read it right
right away where she was like are they
mayday they're pretty mean
so she had that bad vibe already there
it was really cool though seeing this
war-torn city here they're driving
through
i like the show needs to go into more
world building and it's doing that
changing setting up just interesting i
think people really want to know
what this whole country is like and it's
interesting that we're moving towards
chicago
and that the next episode is titled
chicago which makes me really excited
oh my lord and then when they go in with
this guy
and he's like which one of you are
staying with me i was like oh
no and he's like nothing's free here
so june's like not her and she knows
janine's starving here
she's woozy june does the right thing
but this guy is like maybe the scum yes
we've seen yet because he goes
guess you're used to this oh i i really
thought june here and i
wanted to do it was gonna bite this
guy's wee-wee off and he's like i'm not
gonna force you guys can just go
so basically he's saying you don't have
to do this but if you don't do it you
got to leave right i'm not going to feed
you
he's just a piece of crap this guy but
there you go gene's like you're not may
they are
he's like what's mayday so literally got
to get out of there
june knows that but this is where it's
really important because
janine says to her did he hurt you
and jun's like no but we have to get out
of here but notice janine says to june
okay but change your clothes first
basically to get june out of there to
distract her
remember janine feels underestimated
right so
right after that she looks up at the guy
up there
she sadly wants to prove herself useful
here and make it that they can stay and
does the deed
and before we get to that final moment
it goes back to the flashback here with
janine
we see that she's actually with caleb
here
and that this was a different baby that
she was gonna have the abortion with but
she goes to a good doctor this time was
understanding
not nosy complete opposite but she has
an important number she's like
there's these crisis pregnancy centers
that lie to women to force them to keep
unwanted pregnancies again going into
this
lore of this like beginning of gilead
philosophy and this fertility crisis
but we see in a happy way and a happy
ending
in the flashback is that janine is
underestimated but
look she proves herself here that she's
capable of doing what she really
believes she needs to do in this
abortion
without these negative voices and
influences trying to give her guilt
and feeling bad about it and scaring her
so she succeeds
sadly and tragically in the present day
she succeeds and
to herself thinking she's not
underestimating can handle things on her
own
but in a bad way because you see what's
brilliant about this last scene is that
that music i'm talking about that flows
through this montage of read it
eating the takeout food to now janine
with
june and janine says we can stay it
wasn't so bad bringing her the food jun
knows exactly what happened
and janine's like he thinks my eye patch
was cool this is really hard to watch
and sad
and this is crushing to june crushing to
the audience
and june says i'm sorry which means so
many things
it's not just a sorry for what just
happened it's a sorry for
underestimating janine and june
growing as a character and realizing
that if she's gonna treat
janine like a baby and that she's not
able to handle things on her own or make
decisions for herself or have kind of
say in what they're doing
janine might act out this way that she's
trying to prove herself
and overcompensate and do things that
she shouldn't be doing to herself
really really excellent writing and just
powerful
powerful closing scene with the music
too
it just all comes full circle guys i'm
gonna give this episode a 10.
call me crazy but i can't find one flaw
in it
which i always find flaws in everything
i review basically i'm so nitpicky i
couldn't i was trying i couldn't
and music's amazing the acting is
amazing the writing is amazing the
cinematography is amazing that goes to
the lighting he's doing here
amazing directing and writing by these
two women just in particular
just awesome and you it proves you don't
always need a big moment
in a show to have a tent you know like
this just clicks on all cylinders just
what the theme is
every faction of it everything counts
here and lands
and it sticks with me i think this is
something i will think about as an
episode
and i thought it's incredible that an
episode four of an already really good
season
can do this because usually you would
think after that big episode 3 it would
kind of
come down and maybe be too slow or just
catch up but it doesn't
do that it slows the pace down but
everything is powerful here and works
and is interesting and keeps you
invested so
it's a 10 for me i think this is one of
the best episodes of the handmaid's tale
ever and if you don't agree right now
watch it one more time
trust me this one is just a masterpiece
now like i said i'm really excited
because i got to interview
madeleine brewer and amanda brugel rita
and janine
and we talk all about this episode in
both
interviews so please check those out i
really appreciate all the support
and i also interviewed nick alma
and mark himself last week so you can
check those interviews out as well
and if you really like what i do here
you can support me by a two dollar
monthly donation you commit to it's a
paypal link down below
that's to just help me get my dream of
doing this full time one day
make more videos for you guys and if you
can just subscribe to the channel in
general that helps me in so many ways
you have no idea
please comment below with your thoughts
i read every comment try to respond as
many as i can
and please follow me at steven's show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time